is that what inspired the film in some
sense it seems like you like to write
about a question and then find the
answer through the film's I I guess I
have been inspired more thematically
when it comes to the films that I have
made like for an example with the
Avalanche incident what kind of
questions does it raise and as you said
before I think it raises question about
gender and the roles that we have in a
couple relationship and since I am a man
of course I'm also using my own life to
try to tell there the movie but yeah so
so more thematically I think that I've
inspired all of sociological studies
when it comes to crisis situations like
for example and I read a study about
airplane hijackings and you can tell
from this study that the frequency of
divorce is extremely high after airplane
hijackings and if some assess something
all of the expectations that we have on
each other when it comes to crisis
situations and that we are getting
disappointed that for an example husband
doesn't act like an action hero when it
comes to real life
you